bonjour et bienvenue dans cette vidéo de
type 2 via un mentaliste avec avec mois
déjà mais en fait je vais transformer
janka en mentalist salut en arrêtant de
se toucher
ouais ou ceja et vous aussi vous allez
pouvoir apprendre ce qu'il apprend en
temps réel et après ce que je vais
t'apprendre tu va le tester directement
en baladant dans la red box parce qu'on
est la section est ce que tu veux faire
travailler le flohic ouais alors tu
regardes bien la camarine tu fais loïc
génériques
loïc générique c'est dans ton corps
ouais mais ça il peut garder exactement
ce passage là et dire j'ai fait un
générique
cette vidéo a été composé en tant que
premier temps je te fais le voir ce que
tu vas savoir faire ensuite
ouais deuxième je t'apprends à le faire
je vous apprends le faire en même temps
et 3e tentacules on
bon on trouve des tentacules mais c'est
en fait on avait dit tu emmènes pas
d'humour avec tapas y est la somme si tu
dis oh merde je vois tu ne l'a pas fait
oui mais du coup mais ses patins servir
puisque c'est violent c'est clair mais
ça passe et j'aime bien ça peut faire
parce qu'il donne au maire s'est fait
aux le puis je le mets sur la chaîne tci
depuis le kilomètre par tout venant le
concept du puits quand même tu peux
l'expliquer vous met à lire dans la
description pour que vous puissiez vous
déchargez vous faisiez spectacle puis
très rapidement c'est un concept
psychologique qui vous permet au lieu de
déverser la n va même sur la chaîne de
fabien ça marche on le dirait fabien des
moches je t'aime pas tes qu'on est tous
avec tes réflexions
ça sert à rien en fait de faire ça
utilisez votre puis classés en fait un
petit creux dans sa main on met son
autre main dedans en forme de tunnel et
on dit fort bien j'aime pas du tout à
gages je regarde juste et vidéo porte
critiquer mais moi je n'entends pas puis
bah non je le dis dans ce jeu les
libyens ont fui je le garde pour moi et
puis ensuite ton puis tu verses de temps
en temps et on a même créé une chaîne
qui est en direct où tu peux des charges
était comme tu veux au lieu de saône à
l'espace commentaire c'est incroyable
c'est un concept du film là c'est
psychologique ça te permet de d'évacuer
des mauvaises pensées
le but du jeu c'est que je vais
apprendre comment on peut faire pour
retrouver la pièce qui est dedans
mains de quelqu'un donc c'est un dans
quelles mains un week end un anglais
sauf que ça va d'une manière quasi
certaine à 100% n'importe quand dans ta
vie bourré aja avec une pièce de
n'importe quelle monnaie du monde tu dis
à quelqu'un mais la pièce d'un ta main
et tend les bras vers moi et aller ici
et pai est ok technique de mentalisme ça
m'a énormément pour moi regarde mais ces
pièces en ligne de t de main et tu t'en
les deux points bien vers moi comme ceci
je suis maintenant de l'autre côté de la
caméra et tu vas tu vas le faire comme
si moi j'étais la caméra comme ça ils
peuvent essayer sans avoir le savoir
pour l'instant tu me la pièce dans une
de tes demain je ne regarde pas
évidemment il faut que tu fasses
confiance
maintenant je peux pas voir en ce
moment- là on s'en fout les boules c'est
tout près donc
et alors je pourrais très bien dire dans
quelle pièce et la main mais je vais
demander à l'oic qui a été déjà été
formés à ça allait ou non quel pied
assez la mort sac à la main et la pièce
non mais ça va quoi tuer ça va loïc est
ce que le rpt est calé dans ta main
gauche t'es sûr que de ton choix là à
commettre % sont ok tu l'as bien formés
loïc ouais ouais bien sûr qu'il a raison
voici ce que tu vas être capable de
faire après pas franchement là mais tu
m'aimes pas poser question rien du tout
je n'ai senti alors il ya effectivement
away [ __ ] moi tu pouvais pas trop ça
sent la pièce à pleurer comme plusieurs
techniques pour apprendre
la première technique c'est celle qu'on
appelle le nose nojaret déjà parlé sur
la chaîne il ya très longtemps donc je
me dis c'est bien aussi de femmes mises
à jour en clair le nez c'est quand tu
vas demander à quelqu'un de mettre la
pièce dans la main le premier truc que
tu as lu demandé c'est qu'ils tendent
les deux bras bien fait samedi au caire
et toi tu te fies juste à laax dunaire
d'accord et avait klaxonné tu va
regarder où est-ce qu'ils pointent un
peu spontanément et c'est très sensible
dans la majorité des cas ça va indiquer
la main incriminés ok si tu lui dis
juste tu mélanges vas-y tu tend les bras
et en fait le visage légèrement désaxé
et on le voit au niveau de la point de
vue nevers la main un cunni ça dépend si
tu es égyptien rouen est de bourbon
ainsi qu'un et enregistre un effet
boomerang et moi mon grand père
année de bourbon louis de bourbon
pourquoi alors cette vieille france jura
d'accord on est très près vers le barca
qu il peut très bien caché ça a dansé
attention je ne dis pas de suivre la
pointe la direction dit des grands lacs
sous les halles belle façon tard à mes
bonbons
exactement il est très bon sur leur âge
avec ses pinceaux à loïc bravo loïc
général
[Musique]
yes tellement on a dérapé c'est un peu
du sadisme ça quand même
je trouverais félin trouve au générique
on garde un regard bas il ya les deux tu
as vu il ya sûr
[Musique]
celui-là - - bensac la même à welch et
si cela il ya un truc fabien juste avant
que le continent sud déjà rien que ça je
ne veux dire [ __ ] tu aurais pas pu me
concentrer et me dire que mon nez peut
potentiellement de montrer et 90 à 70
espèces de tom je fais avoir quoi sert
il ya un autre truc
en fait ce qui est bien c'est de croiser
le nombre de techniques potentiel pour
être sûr sur ta vie l'eau et qui t'a pas
dit je suis sûr à 50% et je suis sûr à
100% il pouvait affirmer ça tout d'abord
j'ai pas sorcier
le deuxième truc c'est de regarder si
les mains ont un léger décalage hockey
dans la majorité des cas on a tendance à
vouloir cacher un petit peu ce qui est
important d'accord alors on n'est pas du
tout le mot n'a été visible mais tu peux
voir un léger décalage et la personne a
tendance à ramener un peu plus prés
verts ale la main qui comporte la pièce
il ya un troisième indice alors lui si
vous voulez faire pour rigoler c'est
assez marrant à faire dans la vraie vie
moi je m'en sers jamais je vous le dis
parce que c'est très marrant et c'est du
sûr à 100%
vous restez bien tourner le et humer la
pièce dans une de tes demain et tu va
lever la main sur ton front la main qui
comporte la pièce tu vas le lever un
certain temps et pendant ce temps-là tu
lui parles sans le regarder il faut
jouer le jeu faut surtout pas regarder
la personne et donc tu trouve des trucs
à lui dire par exemple tu vois ça va tu
vas bien de concentrer et tu va surtout
faire attention à pas bouger ton visage
tout à l'heure pas cherché à me donner
un indice donc tu lambrou tu gagne du
temps d'une gamme du temps et au bout de
cinq à dix secondes comme on vient de
faire là tu lui demandes de tendre les
deux mains face à toi comme on fait
d'habitude et film bien ça loïc regarder
gagne 2 m 2 mac et plus blanche que
l'autre c'est la main qui à la mise à
parce qu'en fait en la tenant sur le
front le sang est descendu de la main
quoi qu'en fait elle est légèrement plus
blanche ok attend le sang est
redescendue et c'est aussi bête que ça
pensez à tous les petits paris en
famille mais oui c'est exactement ça
s'il revient là des petits pas mais là
vous rendez pas contre l'argent de poche
que vous êtes en train de nous faire si
vous êtes jeune et l'argent tout court
que vous faites si vous êtes un petit
peu plus adulte et la repas de famille
tu dis tonton
mais la tangente à masisi s'il n'a pas
déjà bu cinq whisky coca mais ça de lui
repart tu veux un repas de famille
vraiment tu peux te faire de l'argent
facile donc première technique
almarcha 80 90 % c'est la direction de
l'acce nasale deuxième technique là ça
marche plus dans 50 70%
d'ailleurs la personne a tendance à
cacher un petit peu en rapprochant
d'elle la main qu'un crime et la
troisième technique elle marche dans
100% des cas par contre donc ça c'est du
suicide
si tel n'est pas trop se tromper que ça
fait chier leur a désiré à tous ses fils
et comme s'attaque la main par dessus
voilà nous allons fort de ceux ci partir
dans la red box avec des cas qui va
essayer de le faire à tous ceux qui
croisent et on va compter les points et
vous aussi vous essayer de le faire
maintenant plus évidemment pas ce que
vous allez voir utiliser les mêmes
techniques c'est parti loïc genot y voit
un prêt pour le combat
je serai bien connu on dirait à lui bref
c'est moi votre cas pas de moi j'ai
envie dit bluffé aujourd'hui tu veux
nous bluffer
ok alors là on vient de les rencontrer
avant moi bon ça on sait pas du tout ce
que vous tombez oui j'ai tout c'est vrai
qu'il ya un truc il s'est formé au
mentalisme à ok d'accord
attends je me mets à tu veux on va y
aller par est là je viens de rencontrer
ces deux personnes totalement par hasard
ce que tu les connais la connais pas je
sais que tu t'attendais pâte rencontrer
du monde ici fabrice soit aussi lui qui
n'est pas du tout les cannellonis mois
générique pour les meyer du tout de la
vie tu vois ça c'est une pièce d'accord
est ce que tu veux je me dis regarde pas
ouais bon ce départ car les bras je peux
analyser a juste eu la malice comme je
le paie encore ce qui va se passer
et oui il a des finances qui va se
passer valentin c'est que je vais la
mettre dans une de tes mains pour avec
qui me connais pas tu que même mon
prénom mais j'arrive à celle pour les
couche-tard fait quand je venais voir un
mec qui se fait devenu le prénom c'est à
trèbes le fais ce que j'ai écouté je
joue le jeu s'appelle nous allons
toujours des balles et ne valant pas ça
fait plaisir d'avoir des jumeaux un
prénom le cheveux raccourcissent et les
gens comme sandy gill avait le même
prénom mais oui c'est plus simple pour
les retrouver le très connu
bah moi c'est logique tas de gosses
pareil petit ya deux exemplaires de
chips à géant
ils vont l'appeler la même manière alors
j'ai une quasi la même dans le moule mon
gars non tu vas tu avais dans une des
deux mains ok et travers les temps je
dois trouver le calme à celle de l'atoll
ont essayé de deviner en camerounais
attend s'ajuster à une chanson de noël
comment on va le faire 20 fois la daf
idée on va voir la stat c'est bon tu vas
au total six mois tu tentes et moi je
dirais valentin médicis à raison fait
très fort je vous sers le secret comment
un tweet alors attention ce que la ville
est à la charge de commander 7 de la
chance oui mais je recommence je
recommençais léopard commence mais
l'adjointe à la poche rails les
[ __ ] il est vrai qu est-ce qui a tu
vas faire quoi la pièce le m
je suis là je comprends pas ce qui se
passe attendant un jour c'est en tout
cas tu aurais dû qu'à la pièce du vous
c'était un petit peu flou y a un truc
dans ce style fabien et que je me tourne
et de zoom bien sûr je pense que dans
cette main il se trouve la pierre on a
fait un bon oui j'avais dit que ça se
passait comme ça tu es medimmune gars tu
terrena et il s'avère ok c'est un truc
par rapport à la psychologie on a tu
sais où je les mettrai tout dans ok
c'est bon valentin la pièce sous la
porte
mais [ __ ] je te kiffe mais il me
fallait première partie des spectacles
en questionnant kessler p première
partie de voter je voulais qu'il faut
savoir dire les spectacles pour les 60
prochains mois je me suis alors là je
suis vraiment heureux et rendu bleus là
je suis aménagé alors qu'il a hélas
hélas un bien et est un dernier test
c'est tellement ouf
à la pièce moi j'aurais dit le je crois
attention c'est du bluff non tu sais
quoi c'est eux le vrai mentaliste alors
j'étais cool moi je pensais la gestion
des niveaux bas franchement je vous
baise maintenant et ça me saoule en fait
ça me saoule quand je me fais avoir mais
j'aimerais juste dans une forêt pauline
marie tu as une pièce les abonnés aussi
bien d'être formées en même temps que
durban en fait c'est compliqué non je
rigole mais la caisse qui alors
et face à l'attachement des six mois je
reviens sur votre phrase de tout à
l'heure il ya une chance sur deux
combien de fois on l'a vu échouer sa
règle selon les envies fictifs ou pas en
vrai de vrai mais vraiment au dos mais
son actif à ce que tu kiffes ma vie qui
fut ma vie de mentalist vivement
vendredi six points dans les
commentaires si vous aussi vous aviez
perdu pour la paix j'ai une question qui
veut cela mentaliser par mois chez
l'auteur c'est bon c'est bon
moi je dirais qu'elle est là oui moi
aussi jolie une chanson nous attend
excusez moi je prends juste le relais
pour voir comment fonctionne t gaucher
ou quoi non ok tu penses à la houille la
pièce le plus d'offres comme si elle est
un peu plus long pour moi déjà je me
sens un coup pour voir et à décharge
il est plus compliqué j'ai l'impression
que c'est ton premier défi parce que
pour l'instant il a cartonné de haut sur
lequel les parties pouvaient croiser
c'est à dire 7 me et c'est plus dur
ouais c'est plusieurs mais je dirais
quand même quelle est la jolie qu'est
son prénom estimant exactes
donc tu ne ferais rien fait sur quentin
quant à une chose est sûre c'est que
dans cette main il ya peu la pièce elle
est mort hélas de plus en plus rapide
une dernière fois pour montrer que
vraiment comme je le disais dans cette
malle à toi tu penses quelque chose moi
je pense que tu dois toujours me la
chose extrêmement content en fait là
c'est la chicha
double hommes double pas beaucoup
d'infos ce cas c'est vrai on arrive à
double pad entre c'était cool ou pas
mais attends ça te fait quoi comme
sensation de réussir ta il ya eu un fail
sur tout ce qui est une statistique
normal on peut jamais avoir bon dos
importante
vraiment tous les jours ouais ça vous
mêmes des frissons aouedj elle a réussi
à chaque fois même pas réussir mais de
le faire c'est un espèce de stress
analyse à tous et est allé on vit en
fait d'y arriver
quant à les codes tu fait vachement plus
attention et tu penses après tout lui
dit et ce que je regarde le nez il va
sans doute et d'intrigués tous et à une
certaine pression et quand tu réussis
[ __ ] c'est les voies cela poteo
potentiel pour voir antoine cahen au
regard des jeux film raciste un orgasme
au mental eh bien je vais te laisser ce
mot là de la fin et comme ça je fige ce
moment laisser un pouce si vous avez
aimez cette vidéo pensez à vous abonner
si c'est pas encore fait c'est important
vous vers les nouvelles vidéos mais
c'est aussi important pour moi ça envoie
un signal fort à youtube quand vous
abonnez vous avez ici la vidéo de la
semaine dernière ici une vidéo un peu
dans le même style qui devrait vous
plaire
dans la description je voulais la
dernière vidéo qu'on a fait avec jackass
sur ta chaîne sur l'accolade c'est
logique en se deux salles deux ambiances
social deux ambiances et merci mon pote
et à très bientôt
ciao